now but you said you you need the time
to learn lines but you're talking about
rehearsing two weeks before an episode
but aren't you going right into another
episode even even at the end of the
season when they get backed up on
writing
you're still gonna you're still gonna
get that script five days so you'll
have five but you're still shooting the
other ones yeah
so during the day when you already know
stuff you'll run it yeah
you'll do that you'll do it afterwards
because there's not a lot of time so
you're exhausted
you're working all the time you're
exhausted you're working have you ever
hit a wall where you're like
yes i i i think first season in the
first season
well first of all i was in every scene
except for one
episode i wasn't in at all but in every
other thing
i was in every scene it was [ __ ] nuts
did you complain
i listen i approach this whole thing
like
oh i guess i'll just have more lines
it's the same job
acting i'm not going to pretend it's
different
and while i was diluting myself a little
bit
compartmentalizing and deluding myself
but
um then you know it was just a
fuckload of of words and i just dug in
and got to it and got to it and gave it
up my all and they kept pushing my call
and people don't know what that means
but they just
kept pushing his if he has to wake up at
eight like you know they're working
later in the night so the next day they
push it from eight to nine a.m to ten
a.m
and they just kept pushing my call like
and and they would also say well you uh
which basically means you're not getting
enough sleep and you also don't have
time to rehearse which i said
we do and i was used to doing for
breaking bad and wanted to carry on and
better questions
and you're doing 12-hour days too right
you're doing 12-hour 14-hour days so
your 12-round turnaround it's called the
like a turnaround sometimes they'd say
hey do you mind if we force you so the
crew doesn't have to do that they would
say
do you mind if we force you do you mind
if we force you do you mind if we force
you and i would sign it every time i
knew you're like
i was so thankful that we were making
this show and i didn't want anyone to
have any problem because of me yeah yeah
i mean i'll just
i'll just work harder i kept asking uh
the ad
like can i can i say no because they
would always say
this was the real shitty thing because
they would never say
you don't have to do this they didn't no
they would always say
hey uh we need you to we need to force
your call
so we need we need to do it for blah
blah blah blah blah blah and then they
look at me and i'd be like
no compassion well no like okay you need
we'll do it i guess like in other words
they wouldn't i know but they would
never present it to me that way
it was like we need to and it's like
i think you're just informing me of what
you need to do right let me ask you
about it
if i would have said all right you don't
have to tell me that even why do you
even have to tell me that the way you're
talking is so weird
you don't have to tell me that just give
me the sheet that says i have to wake up
earlier
and then a couple weeks into that and i
was getting really fatigued and i lost
my voice and
um and uh i was like can i
are you asking me are you telling me and
even when i'd say that question they
would go well
it's just that we can't make they
wouldn't answer the question
it was driving me [ __ ] crazy never
seen that yeah
and then finally i found an ad this is
like
week six or seven and episode like five
where they were going to force the
weekend call that's the only time to
rest
like in other words we were shooting
until around seven a.m on saturday
morning
right friday into saturday friday friday
at 7
6 00 p.m we shot until saturday at 7 00
a.m
so you really have barely a day and then
monday we start at 5
30 a.m i hope you fire this first ad
so we need to force your call the
weekend call you can't have your 36
hours that's when you put your foot down
that was the point where i said can i
say
no and this person
looked at me and said i think the crew
would really appreciate it if you said
no
wow cause the crew's dying too they're
[ __ ] dying they're [ __ ]
slaving they must think i'm an [ __ ]
you're a muslim yes to this over over
and over and over again i'm like i
thought i had to say yes you didn't even
offer it to me as a question and so i
said well [ __ ] no then
and then i got on top of it